[Music]
what's up test123 has uh hello hi guten
tag guten morgen hello my name is Shawn
Larkin did you get a little bit of wet
in the snow today maybe some kind of
okay so yes my name is Shawn Larkin and
the name of this talk is as it was
mentioned everything is a plug in
mastering webpack from the inside out
right so how many of you have heard of
this tool called webpack how many here
use it today empowers your production
websites all right keep your hands held
please please how many here know how it
works
look around look around well I hope
today it's the last time you don't get
to raise your hand for that
so this correct I'm a program manager at
Microsoft I work on Microsoft edge the
team that I work for is called ecosystem
and so our single purpose is to make
sure that our engagements with
frameworks build tools anything related
to JavaScript in the web are heard as we
design and create new features but you
may know me as one of the maintainer x'
of the web pack open source project
conveniently we also have two other
maintainer x' here the original creator
of web pack tobias raise your hand yes
so there's Tobias and also Johanna save
odds raise your hand yes so he's back
there as well so come say hi to us mmm
um and I'm also huge evangelist for open
source and a representative on for the
node.js foundation and the modules group
and on the web assembly community group
so a little bit about myself is that I'm
a I'm a former tech support rep gone
rogue I got tired of not being able to
solve people's problems
I actually went to school for church
music so I was going to be a cop held my
stuff and seriously for the University
and but I I started learning how to
program and you know I eventually found
JavaScript and fell in love I also loved
sustainable open-source and building
ecosystems just like web pack and for
other projects as well and you can find
me so like if you have a Twitter if you
have LinkedIn whatever any of those
things I'm at the Lark in so you can
find me there but none of this today
would be powered without like our main
sponsors like Chirag Oh who here knows
what trivago is it's a german company
based in Dusseldorf the team is here I
think also so one of the things I want
to talk about is without any of the work
none of this would be possible without
our major contributors like trivago
also any of these companies here if you
work for them you know you could raise
your hand or stand up but we would not
be here without these open source
contributions who help sponsor and fund
our project so before I you know I go on
I let's give them a hand
thank you so much thank you seriously
we might not have what back three four
or even five coming down the road so
everything is a plug in mastering
webpack from the inside out so these are
the the things that I want to do today
is that first we're gonna maybe walk
through a little bit of the web pack
source code don't worry it's not that
intimidating once we break it apart
we're gonna learn what a web pack
plug-in is and its anatomy and then have
ultimate power these are my goals for
you and you know selfishly us as a team
like we want your help we want your
contributions and even I mean even
before we continue you know we have to
talk about web pack as a architecture
and a system so we have this library
called tappa Bowl web pack Tappin Bowl
is our plugin system that is built into
the web pack open source project and it
used to be about a 200 line plugin
library it's now increased in size a
little bit but it represents the
backbone of the entire system without it
web pack would be nothing it has what we
call a series of hooks or events who's
used event emitter before in nodejs
many okay good well you can think of
this as similar so we have these hooks
that live on piece on instances or
important classes in web pack and each
of these define different parts of the
lifecycle that you know happens within
web pack and so if we look at this
example here we have we have a class
it's the easiest way to define a web
pack plugin the only rule is that you
have an apply method and you're gonna
plug in to each of these hooks so we
provide you the top-level instance
called the compiler
and you can plug into these events and
add additional functionality or features
here's one with some some J stock
annotations but just another example
here we're hooking into the the make
event and now you have access to a
compilation and and here's another one
you know you can plug into multiple
events it's not just one and the
beautiful part here is that all of
webpack uses this entire system so I
know it might be hard to see on the
screen but if you look in the webpack
source code 80% of it is plug ins so
you're probably familiar if you've used
webpack you've seen a plug-in before in
your configuration webpack uses this
entire system so webpack is a completely
event-driven a plug-in based compiler
and you know you go on here everything
is plugins in web pack even to collect
the entry point and create and start
kicking off the dependency graph and I
kind of go through a couple of examples
here so why why do we care about plugins
then because if you understand how to
create and a plug-in itself then you
know how the hell wet pack works so
we're gonna talk about what we call
tappa belen stencil and what does it
mean when I say that
so topical instance is just something
that extends or uses these events or
hooks aka something you can plug into
and in our system we not only have just
a single thing you plug into you this
plug-in system allows you to hook into
events that return other things that you
can plug into so the compiler returns a
compilation and you plug into a deeper
part of the life cycle of webpack so
what I'm going to do today is talk about
each of these capital instances and then
we're going to kind of string together a
story so that you see why these are all
importance so the compiler
who has ever used a compiler before or
outside a web Packer knows what it is
took computer science so you're familiar
with what a compiler does and these are
just names that we've given these these
instances so the compiler instance
itself is the top-level event it has
everything to do with the starting and
stopping of webpack any sort of
top-level API is that you're going to
use I like to consider it central
dispatch or hot bun HOF you can say it
is the main station in which things
operate and you can use a compiler
instance straight from the node API and
this is how people who use the node API
command-line tools that leverage webpack
they're using it you have access
directly to that compiler instance the
second is called the compilation and may
be easily described as the dependency
graph so the dependency graph is
basically the the meat and potatoes of
webpack is it contains this depth
dependency graph traversal algorithm
lots of big names what you need to know
is it's how web pack understands which
sources you're actually using in your
code base and it's created by the
compiler you can call it the brain and
then we have what's called the resolver
who knows what a resolver is who uses
nodejs and you know it doesn't have to
use a fully qualified path right so
that's what the node resolver does it
allows you to type a partial path and
returns implicitly a full absolute path
so it actually knows that file exists so
a good example is if we use this this
comic and that I've drawn here is that
we'll take a partially resolved file
we'll pass it to the resolver and say
hey go make sure it exists right and if
it does we want this and this
information and so you can see here it
goes and finds it and it returns a bunch
of useful things that's necessary for
to collect the source and you can see
here that the resolver itself as I said
is pluggable and so therefore we already
have a bunch of plugins created behind
the scenes in a separate library that
allow you to have all the customization
you want in webpack and the next we have
what's called the module Factory who's
ever written Java before who's ever had
to use a factory like
something-something factory factory yes
you know you get it so you can blame
Tobias for this name but um the module
Factory is responsible for creating an
object and in this case it's the module
itself the representation and so it
takes a successfully resolved request
with the source information that we need
and it collects that source it reads the
file and then it stores it in this this
object in memory and we're going to use
it later so if we depicted this it might
look like this
information that we need about a file we
send it through the module Factory and
out comes this beautiful module right
wow so pretty and then the parser who's
ever written a parser cool you might oh
wow ok who knows how a parser works or
knows what an ast is very cool excellent
so a parser is well what does it do it
parses so it takes a string and it
converts it into a tree a tree form that
makes it easy for any sort of program or
compiler to walk the source text of the
file that's been written and it turns it
into this this object called an ast or a
tree and it makes it easy to walk and so
in this case we do the exact same thing
we parse the file and we create an AST
bot we do something special we walk
through this this ast and we look for
specific statements imports requires
dynamic imports and we mark we create we
trigger an event and we say hey add a
dependency to this module object we
create what's called dependencies
so you can say we pass the module
through our parser glasses and we look
for those requires and imports and it we
attach these dependency instances to the
module itself now you can see I've
shaded these with individual colors
because there are many different types
right we have common je s we have es
imports we have the dynamic import
statement and webpack supports all of
them and so we have to understand which
ones were used inside that file and then
finally template who uses a template in
their web code everyday you do All Hands
can be raised JSX angular templates view
templating what is the templates purpose
it's data binding for a view
representation right well in this
specific case we use templates in web
pack because it's data binding for your
graph it's data binding for the
dependency graph itself and what it
renders is the actual code you see when
web pack runs so like your bundle we
have all these abstractions right so we
have a chunk template we have a module
template we have dependency templates we
have a main template and each of these
has a render function that will take the
data it's bound to and it will then
create the strings the string
representation now if you're familiar
with the web pack like output of the
code you'll notice at the far right this
looks almost identical to that you have
your main templates you have each
function in the if e and so we're just
taking and rendering this entire graph
into a string if you wrote it in react
and you use the string renderer it might
look like this right you have some sort
of compilation you'd say for each chunk
and then for each module inside each
chunk generate you know and render
so but if we take a step back now I know
this looks confusing don't worry what do
we look at all of our tappa Belen census
now and so we start with the compiler it
says run we read the configuration
object provided by the user or the
default values and then we take and
access the entry point right but it's
not a result we don't it's only a
partial path right so we send it through
the module factory to the resolver we
verify it exists we pull the at the
entire source and then we return the
module then we go and we parse that file
we collected source and we look for
other dependency statements right
and we attach them to that instance and
then we say well for each dependency on
that module its unresolved right so
repeat the step for each dependency and
you might be like why Sean stop that's
way too fast so I broke it down so we
start with the entry point right we
collect let's say index IJ s we have to
take this and resolve this into an
absolute path right we attach this to a
module object and we give it an ID too
so we have to access it later the ID can
change depending on your environment
it's not as important but we create a
module object we have the source code
now now we have to parse it and as we're
walking the ast we found two more
dependencies so we attach them as edges
in our graph and now we repeat this
process we take that unresolved
dependency we now create a module out of
it we collect the source we resolve it
and repeat so you repeat those steps
until you have no more dependencies but
I've just talked about building the
graphs I know this this one is even more
fun but how does how does this graph
actually turn into something that's
usable in the browser right so I have a
little comic strip that I wrote so it's
like hi I'm a module I can't wait to
work in the browser and we're like we're
the compilations let's boil there cool
your jets we need to get you in the
shape so first jump in this container
you need to keep track of you we're
gonna move you around and topologically
sorry yeah and we don't want to lose
track of you it's like wow I'm so cozy
I've been shuffled around and sorted
topologically are we there yet yeah has
all its dependency references on it
we're almost there but we have a problem
those required import statements have to
go they don't work in the browser so the
parser gave me special instructions to
render those dependencies we call them
dependency templates and factories and
out of the factory it goes into this
string it says wow I'm finally rendered
here I come browser land and you just
learned how web pack works entirely
under the hood what you did that is
entirely how web pack works under the
hood now to be as might be back there
like you missed a step but I'm just
covering the most important parts
covering the most important parts and
this was my like watch what that's it it
took me by surprise at first it may take
you by surprise at first but why should
I care Sean I just want just let me
write some web code I just will write
some web it's like it's okay because now
that you understand every instance and
every piece of the lifecycle and how it
works because web pack is an
event-driven
plug-in architecture it means you can
take and extend any single piece of web
pack to do anything that you want
literally so you might be like wow Sean
that's interesting where can I start so
we have lots of opportunities this
originally used to be a used to be a
workshop for creating plugins but now I
find it to be more interesting to teach
people just how it works under the hood
not only so that you can better
understand it appreciate it but also
extend and
make it work for your workflow so I do
have a github repository called
everything is a plug-in you can always
take a look at it and I also have it's a
little dated by version but it helps you
learn the concepts of using webpack
itself and not its architecture you can
get a web packed out Academy and these
courses are free we wanted to be able to
have something that's entry level that
anybody could access and obviously I had
to learn this at one point when I
started out as a maintainer I only had
one commit to the project I don't even
think maybe the commit landed when I
joined so when I wanted to talk about
web pack I was terrified or even
contribute and so I went through the
entire source code and with my surface
and pen I annotated every piece of the
source code and so I shared those images
you know on github so if you ever want
to take a look
it's called artsy web pack tour so this
is where I learned how to actually
generate these slides and create the
content and hopefully all of these
things that I've talked about today are
on our Doc's and if not you can always
do a PR so web patches org slash API dot
plugins take a look at it
and I mean we always want your
contributions so triaging helping with
these core plugins and loaders and
finally just using webpack 5 so thank
you very much and hopefully you have
some things to think about an extending
web pack for the future
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]